يجهزهم لامر ما يحث الرئيس الصيني هؤلاء
وغيرهم من الجنود على تحسين قدراتهم من
اجل قتال فعلي يريد من جيشه التاهب دوما
للدفاع عن سياده الصين الاقليميه وحقوقها
البحريه لا ضير في ذلك كله لولا ان ظرف
مرتبط اشد الارتباط بتايوان
التي تعد الجزيره المتمتعه بحكم ذاتي جزءا
من اراضيها ترفض اي مسعا منها للانفصال
والاستقلال
بعد مناورتهم العسكريه الاخيره التي حاكت
تطويقه تايوان بالكامل يستعد الصينيون
لفرض حظر جوي على شمال الجزيره صباح الاحد
المقبل لمده نصف ساعه
هذه منطقه حظر طيران اقامتها الصين تقع
داخل منطقه تحديد الدفاع الجوي انها تبعد
حوالي 85 ميلا بحريا شمال تايوان
ينبه التايوانيون الى ان اي حظر للطيران
في اجوائهم سيسبب ما يصفونها بمخاطر جسيمه
للملاحه الجويه في المنطقه
وتلفت وزاره دفاعهم النظر الى مخاطر من
نوع اخر فقد تعاقبت كما قالت 35 طائره
عسكريه صينيه في محيط تايوان يبدو ان على
تايوان ان تخشى ما هو اكثر من ذلك واخطر
لن اهون من شان طموح الصين الى الهيمنه
على تايوان ولكن تقديراتنا تفيد القياده
الصينيه تخامرها شكوك في امكانيه غزو
الجزيره من دون ان تدفع ثمنا باهضا نعم
امر الرئيس الصيني الجيش بالاستعداد لغزو
تايوان بحلول سنه 2007
ولكن هذا لا يعني بالضروره وقوع حرب بحلول
تلك السنه او ما يليها
الى تقارير استخباريه امريكيه تفيد
باعتزام الصين ضمه تايوان بعد اربع سنوات
من الان مع ذلك لا تجد واشنطن داعيا
لتصعيد الموقف يقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
ان هدف بلاده هو السلام والامن والاستقرار
وخلق فرص وليس الدخول في حرب بارده جديده
ولا احتواء الصين والصين هي من يهدد
بالحرب تقول تايوان تايوان التي تؤكد
استعدادها للدفاع عن نفسها ترد الصين
بالقول ان السلطات الحزب الديمقراطي
الحاكم في تايوان مستعده لتحويل الجزيره
الى برميل بارود في رساله تتعدى تايوان
الى الاقليم تذكر بيجن من تسميها بعض
الدول بانه ليس بامكان القوات الاجنبيه
حمايتها بل انها كما تضيف ستفاقم التوتره
وتجلب لنفسها الكوارث